how many auditions did you have Will and
Grace was about six six in front of the
studio the network yeah it started with
just the writers and I I kind of knew
after that first audition that I was
their pick but then it was it was it was
weirdly before Christmas and
um pilot season didn't usually start
till late January early February so it
just felt too early and I kind of backed
away and I don't know it was just it
just it took a long time and then by the
time I had the role it was another month
before Deborah Messing
came in they always wanted her but she
wasn't available and I read with a whole
bunch of women it was a long process